[Music]
let's go to tommy in bentonville
arkansas bentonville home of walmart is
that right tommy
it's the home of walmart and crystal
bridges
i don't know crystal bridges do they
sell drugs there what is crystal bridge
you know what it sounds like they do
don't they but it's a fun place to go
visit lots of lights outdoor trails
there's no drugs at crystal crystal
village
it does kind of sound like a mystical
place where it does doesn't it yeah but
yes walmart's here there are no drugs at
walmart none
never so what's up t-money how can i
help it
well dr john my parents are my in-laws
they actually just got a job where they
have the summers off
and they wanna
i i'm laughing at you not with you on
this one
i know because i i'm not i'm not
laughing i was
until it became real
oh man okay so i i'm just guessing where
this is headed but go ahead
they would love to spend a month with
each kid
and their kids and their spouses
yes and
um and so they did tell us originally
they said we could stay in an extended
stay
but then they haven't brought that up
again but i do know a month with them
here means they're every day
with
um
my wife and me and it just it doesn't it
sounds so exciting
yes like dude i'm so happy for you you
know what you're gonna have someone to
critique how you mow the lawn how you
make breakfast how you what you watch at
night when you go to bed you're closed
it'll be so good now not all in-laws are
like that if my in-laws wanted to move
in for a month i would love that it'd be
incredible oh great it doesn't sound
like that is your situation tell me
about it
so my in-laws they they truly are great
people
they would be your conservative
religious
uh
type of person i guess if i put a
stereotype um they might i'll put it
this way my wife just let her mom know
this year that we drink alcohol
and uh we're in our 30s
yes
i was going to make a joke but that i'm
not even going to go there
how did that conversation go was it hard
uh it was hard for my wife
but because you know she's never really
separated herself uh in a conversation
like that with her parents and it was
really healthy her mom responded well
her dad is the one that i think
you know he's pretty legalistic it's his
way of the highway it's his
interpretation of the bible or no way um
and he just
you know he's not talkative he's not
conversationalist
just hard to be around for an extended
period of time okay um so i i think that
my concern dr john is i think it's great
that we differentiate from her parents
but i you know i'm like more than three
nights a week for a month sounds like a
whole lot and and i want to live my life
in the month of june
yes so
two two questions what is number one
what does your wife think of this
uh i have more anxiety than she does
okay so
she she has asked me before
you know why why does that make you
you tell anxious
truth
i do yeah i do tell her the truth yeah
even when you say do you say things like
i don't like you when you're around them
because you regress 20 years and you
become a 10 year old and it becomes
awkward for us
are you that i haven't said that no i
haven't said that is it truthful
um i don't think she regresses 20 years
i do think that she
uh doesn't want you know she doesn't
want to offend her parents okay so i
think that i think i need to have that
conversation with her i don't want to
offend my parents but i also don't
consider my life an offense
do you see the difference there
yeah like yeah i see what you're saying
i will not bring whiskey like in your
situation i wouldn't bring
even fancy bourbon i wouldn't bring it
into my parents house
yes but i'm not going to
deceive them and go through a big hiding
ritual every time they're coming over
when i'm in my 30s i'm not gonna do that
and
and you know what what's funny is i do
collect fancy whiskey and we used to
hide it and then it was like we're not
doing this anymore and so you can see
we're just at the beginning stages there
you go okay trying to be healthy with my
in-laws yeah okay cool
so that's why i have anxiety around this
yeah so and the second question is do
you have little kids
i do we have a nine-year-old they're
both girls nine-year-old and
six-year-old okay all right
man
so
i can speak from like if my in-laws want
to come i'd love that i think it'd be
fun but here's the differentiation
i live my life and my wife and i
are
completely differentiated from our
parents
meaning we do what we do
and if there's a sunday that we don't
want to go to church but we want to
spend it as a family and we're going to
go hiking and do our thing and that's
what we do i don't feel like i gotta
hide from people
if i have my dad and i have radically
different political views my mom and i
have we are in sync on some things
super non-sync on other things some
things my dad and i
i just i don't care
you know what i mean like i'm interested
in the intellectual sparring
but i'm not gonna fight anybody
especially not my parents or my in-laws
you know what i mean and so i
i'm there
what i
would caution you on is
you're just in a hard place brother
because your your in-laws
did a couple of things number one they
gave you the old well we could just stay
in an extended stay motel
great cool y'all go ahead and do that
you can do that
and
um if i don't know how that would fly i
know how to fly my house
um
so the second thing is now i mean they
kind of
introduce themselves into your home
second thing is it sounds like there's
some marital tension here
and you've got to be very careful about
talking bad about your wife's parents
is she sensitive about that
no she's been really gracious and she
sees it uh she sees that hey we have
totally different lives than her parents
and we've we've even talked about so she
has done really well and i do feel like
i'd be honest with her um and i've told
her
it is hard for me to be around your dad
for an extended period of time okay tell
me why why is it hard
yeah i've been
uh like why do you care and i'm just
gonna sound i'm i'm being provocative on
purpose why do you care if he just wants
to sit over there
and watch fox news and be angry let him
like why why does that bother you
well that that is a fault for of mine
for sure because i think i'm like let's
do something and let's engage in
conversation or let's have fun together
i i i think for me that's what i would
like to do
and it i don't i don't know why it
bothers me so much i don't i wish i
hadn't
do you wish this is going to be a hard
ques
do you wish he liked you
or is there a sense that your
father-in-law just doesn't like you that
much or would like you more if you had
different life views or different
lifestyles
yeah i think i think i feel like i'm
being judged by him when we're not
engaging in a relationship there you go
and you feel like he's not in a
relationship with you because of some
judgment he's placed on you
possibly yes yes
okay
now i feel like we're getting at the
core issue here
you my friend
need to be confident tommy
okay and you need to be confident as
a husband of a great wife
as of the dad of two great daughters
yeah and more importantly you need to be
confident in these are my life choices
these are my life philosophies these are
my life
decisions and it's mine
and if somebody wants to be a guest in
my house that's fantastic i would be
hospitable and kind and if they don't
want to talk to me
that is their loss
because i'm pretty awesome
and i'm going to go talk to other people
or i'm going to take my kids and we're
all going to go fishing and if my
father-in-law wants to sit down and
stare at his phone that's a choice he's
going to make but i'm not going to own
his choice
and what i would tell you is you're
chasing a fantasy and i'm not saying
it's an ugly you're chasing a fantasy
that there is going to be a thing one
day y'all are going to align
and i want to tell you you are not
there won't be an alignment
there may be a arms like a
ceasefire like in my in my house we made
some rules no politics no covet like we
can't talk about it
so i made those conversation cards like
where i refuse to have these
conversations just because it doesn't it
doesn't get anywhere
um and so we are done with this
um in fact yeah i'm going to do this i'm
going to give you i'm going to send you
three decks of cards i'm going to send
them to you okay
and whenever this inevitably happens
which is going to you can practice over
the holidays and then when they move in
with you
and gee it's so great
uh you can have them but they're just
cards like hey here's some other things
to talk about
and
if he chooses not to engage what i want
you to begin practicing is
it's not your responsibility to chase
down a relationship with him it's your
responsibility to be respectful and
those are two different things
this is so helpful does that make sense
yeah do i do you think i need to sit
down with or call him and just say hey
this is kind of who i am you know
this is do i need to have that
conversation with them about when you're
in our house all the things that you
said about
you know our house is if we have a glass
of wine together fine we want to go out
together with the kids
so is that a healthy conversation to
have i
i
one of my life rules is to speak to be
heard not to have having said had said
something
and i said that kind of bonkers
there are some people that when when an
action happens like an injustice happens
or somebody gets offended or whatever
they make sure that they spoke on that
issue
i want on the record that i said
something about that it's like living
your life like a politician
i choose to only speak when i can be
heard
what that often means is i'm not posting
stuff the day after something happened
because everybody's fired up nobody's
listening
or my father-in-law has the way he lives
it's the way he lives
and so if i call him what he will hear
in about eight seconds
is i don't like the way you live and if
you're coming into my house you're gonna
live like this and then he's going to
turn into an old labrador and see who
can pee up the tree the highest
and again i'm speaking into your
father-in-law i don't know that guy from
the man of the moon
i'm telling you i would more like to
take all of the air and drama out i
don't know that it's worthy of a
conversation you have a glass of wine at
dinner
great
when he's there and y'all are having
dinner
then you say hey you guys want a glass
of wine
and you just like as though it is hey
will you pass the
fork because right now it's y'all's
heart rate that's getting up not theirs
and then if they come to your house and
you all respectfully offer them a glass
of your nicest wine
and they decline and then they want to
throw grown-up temper tantrums about
that that's their challenge not yours
okay
and so i'm more interested in
yeah if there's one or two things that
you think would be fun if he likes to go
ride go-karts or go fishing or go
hunting whatever it is if you think
there's things there that would be great
yeah set him up see if he wants to go he
might just say no i don't want to go
and then you got to swallow it and go
that's his issue not mine
and by the way i'm
dating his daughter so i win ah you know
what i mean
um and he may just
he you may be thinking about y'all's
relationship way more than he is
yeah well i would like
i mean my there's things i want with my
own dad that i don't have yeah and i
know
see now we're getting at the issue i
know we are and i know that i'm like oh
i don't want to be and you're trying to
transfer your dad's you and your dad's
relationship issues and try to recreate
something with your father-in-law yeah i
think though and what i want you to do
is let that fantasy go
okay shake the man's hand when he comes
over here's the thing he's probably
coming over for a month i wish he could
be like no we're gonna say no he's
probably coming
and so sit down and make peace with like
your life decisions and decide to not
hide what i will tell you is secrets or
poison
and secrets will destroy your marriage
secrets will destroy relationship with
your in-laws
don't keep secrets this is who we are
this is how we live now that doesn't
mean we're gonna like
have a discussion on who should be
president that's not gonna be helpful no
um but my guess is that's not your style
anyway
no i don't i don't care to have those
talks and if y'all you know if he grew
up baptist and a strong baptist family
and now y'all go to a different church
that's just where you go don't hide
don't lie don't hide it be proud of who
you are and what decisions you're making
and if you all want to make different
decisions make different decisions but
all of this yeah man we got to it took a
few minutes but
you got some challenges between you and
your dad
and you want to make sure that's not
replicated and you see your
father-in-law's a chance to fix that and
it's not
the way you fix that is in your
relationship with your kids
and the way you can fix that is being
open and loving your nine-year-olds and
being connected to them and letting them
see you have friends and let them see
you not be tense with your life choices
own them own them
own them and be respectful super
respectful
super respectful of your in-laws it's
their choices
um and it may be that hey we're gonna
take the tv out of from downstairs
because i don't want this news blaring
24 7 when they're here they can go
upstairs and listen to it or they can go
in the back room and listen to it we'll
put a tv in your room y'all can just sit
back there and watch tv all you want but
out here we don't watch tv we got
puzzles out we got games out we got
whatever we got the
questions for humans cards that i'm
going to send you so hang on the line
tommy and um kelly will get your
information she'll mail them out to you
and that's just my gift to you to save
your family that's all that's all they
do they just save your family i probably
overstated that a little bit but
tommy you'd be proud of tommy man
love tommy tommy's a good guy he's a
good dad he's a good husband
he's a good guy and if your old man
comes around that's even better
but own tommy let's move on from there